effectivement on peut être aussi en
couple avec des personnes à sexuelle ou
à romantique est un romantique c'est un
peu plus compliqué parce que du coup le
polyamour sa demande des sentiments mais
effectivement on peut être à plusieurs
personnes il faut une autorisation ils
font quoi enfin bon c'est plusieurs ça
commence à 3 on va on va entrer dans les
détails vous êtes alors on n'est pas
forgé sa relation amoureuse avec combien
de personnes à l'heure actuelle je suis
en crush avec deux personnes -deux perçu
voilà et ces deux personnes savez vous
avez été déjà comme nous apprécions
crush crush voilà est-ce que vous avez
déjà été en croches avec plus de deux
personnes a largement d'argent j'étais
en couple si avec lui coupe le polyamour
avec plus est en fait dire combien plus
alors roulé blanc vous dire à 16 ans
j'ai commencé au début un chant à l'âge
de 8 ans à l'âge de huit ans en fait si
vous voulez j'ai deux meilleurs amis qui
sont venus le voir
de fille qui ne voulait qu'ils voulaient
pas se battre pour un homme qui ont
décidé de se mettre avec bas il y admire
qui l'aide et du coup j'ai dit moi j'ai
pas dit non je pense qu'aucun homme peut
dire noir a de jolies demoiselles
mais c'était quand on est jeune
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être la preuve que
le voyait moins naturel parce que quand
on est enfant on attend d'en savoir
beaucoup d'amoureux d'amoureuse et voilà
et si vous voulez pas justement moi je
vous dis aussi bas c'est même moi je me
disais au début c'est pas normal parce
que du coup j'avais une famille qui
était plutôt au mono donc je suis dit
c'est pas forcément normal après
effectivement à l'âge de 16 ans ces
revenus est agitée avec 8 personnes
et la cip au clash connaissez pas le
terme polyamoureux huit personnes ces
huit femmes me favreau d'accroissement
rester vigilants et femmes ensemble
c'est ça qui les huit connaissait la
situation n'est d'accord non là c'est
parce que je connaissais pas tout à fait
le polyamour la wii tout ça elle tout le
feu vidor que c'est pas le polyamour
attend donc du coup à son image que
c'est pas du tout foyer amant du coup
c'est enfin j'aime bien utiliser ce
terme mais j'espère ça va pas de socke
est choqué mais c'était un peu collante
à chaque semaine par jean n'éliminer
nuit
et
vous c'est que vous cessiez de manger et
vérité est arrivée la dernière je suis
arrivé la dernière vous aviez un
secrétariat
et
je suis arrivé à la dernière et du coup
quand je suis arrivé à la dernière parce
que j'avais des sentiments pour conduite
alors bas j'étais totalement dépité donc
la dernière elle devient présidente us
ce jour-là devais me présenter sa
famille m voient arriver avec une tête
d'enterrement parce que je suis content
quand même parce que c'est une femme
italienne donc quand une italienne
présente sa famille c'est une étape
importante
là du coup elle m'a vu avant soyez
souvent déjà avant qu'ils aient voyais
que ça ait de moins en moins bien mais
se poser des questions pme demander sans
cesse pourquoi sa fin si ça allait je
disais oui ça va ça et effectivement
mais je suis totalement dépité au moment
où je devais me présenter famille et m'a
quittée à ce moment là et après
effectivement quelques années après bana
c'est très récent parce que j'ai 32 ans
même si on dirait pas
et du coup j'ai appris à mes besoins de
six ans que j'étais polyamoureux grâce à
une amie qui est qui elle même a vécu le
polyamour à celle qui vous a renseigné
sur le mot poli amorcé sa famille un mot
sur votre situation exacte et en fait on
a été ensemble à vent et on y reste ses
amis après et elle a vécu sa vie et du
coup elle a vécu une relation client
mode et elle m'a dit mme yan en fait
c'est polyamoureux pendant une semaine
j'ai fait non je peux pas il ya un mois
après ma fée bat était amoureux de moi
tu étais amoureux d'une personne enfin
et a souvent été comme ça du coup j'ai
pris une semaine pour réfléchir j'ai
donné rendez-vous à un ami que je vois
souvent pour lui faire pour lui parler
des trucs sérieux j'ai fait ça va on m'a
parlé du polyamour à ce que tu connais
mes coui mes yeux expliqué tout et puis
après j'ai fait non je ne pense pas que
je me souhaite monsieur pouviez mort
après lui il m'a dit directement
clairement pas aussi des polyamoureux je
nous ai dit non non c'est pas un obsédé
est-ce que vous êtes à 32 ans c'est vrai
est ce que vous vous vibrez centrale
huit fois vous avez dit bête relationnel
vous pouvez écrire des lettres en
alexandrins à 8 personnes
nous palais mais le coeur qui se dit
tiens je vais pas laisser passer cette
chance là tout garde sous le coude un
certaine nombre de femmes qui n'a pas
envie de voir leur ibra de dons alors il
faut savoir qu'on était obligé de
l'aimer quelques chansons lancé c'est
intéressant mais c'était il ya longtemps
mais dans les années où là la dent dans
les allées 2019 2020 ces projections
non mais la question est sérieuse est ce
que vous arrivez à vibrer
sentimentalement à huit personnes alors
je vais être sérieux je vais vous dire
déjà on a répondu amoureux ne s'enferme
pas dans une case la preuve il ya des
polyamoureux nous en belgique notamment
qui ont énormément d'avancé sur nous la
belgique la suède comme on disait
d'ailleurs le japon est en fait si vous
voulez bas la belgique j'avais des amis
aux pouilles amour et en belgique qui
sont aujourd'hui en couple mono mais si
aurélie science dit comme s'il y avait
eu des équipes de police maurice
conscience d'avoir exemple vous dire
qu'une seule paire 6 ans une équipe de
handball
c'est qui quadrille
je devrai ce voyage parce que j'ai perdu
a tant fait bien sûr le campath
conduite c'était pas du polyamour but
c'était pas du foyer mairie
d'aujourd'hui en offrant vous avez été
vraiment voilà nos relations à partir de
ce que je suis d'accord avec yann avant
ça s'appelait que tard en fait on dit
que c'est pauline
paulien alors y avait du tout glamour
mais un premier amour sa mission
impressions mais si vous voulez par
contre si vous voulez à partir du moment
que j'ai rencontré une personne qui
était déjà en couple avec une autre
personne qui m'a expliqué que faire à
qualité beaucoup d'amour mais justement
je me suis mis à laquelle il faut savoir
quelle est justement l et demie sexuelle
donc du coup forcément elle a pas
énormément besoin de sexe donc du coup
forcément mais après on a eu nos
péripéties comme tous les couples pour
money money aussi effectivement j'ai été
en couple plusieurs fois et c'est là où
j'ai su que effectivement je sais pas il
ya un mois donc pas d'où ça vous
inquiétez pas je sais reste à préciser
mais je sais que
vous nous avez plutôt le pchr
vous pouvez avoir un personnage un peu
l'action avec les huit amoureux alors
jeu égal avec l'autre jeu est le même
alors je vais te le même et on peut être
plusieurs fut totalement d'accord avec
vous je vais te le même mais par contre
c'est vrai que mon comportement sur le
selon les désirs de chacune enfin c'est
selon et se voit là et
elle sera différente du coup je suis
totalement d'accord avec vous
effectivement et je suis d'accord avec
vous sur le fait qu'on peut être
plusieurs on n'est pas une seule
personne on évolue dans la vie de façon
mais vous cloisonné vous arrivez voir
maintenant justement justement audience
m et yann faux fait une interview vous
demander des conseils
[Applaudissements]